herzlich willkommen in meiner toten hält
heute gibt es bei mir also das heißt ich
habe diesen cocos website gemacht und
ihnen osterlicht dekoriert ihr könnt
diesen natürlich für jedes andere gebäck
nehmen und könnt die kekse so dekorieren
wie ihr wollt
bevor es jetzt weitergeht zum rezept
möchte ich noch kurz in der vorschau
geben
für das nächste video und zwar werde ich
es bald meine küche filme und euch mein
werkzeug und meine hilfsmittel zeigen
und ich habe gesagt dass ich da
vielleicht so eine frage antwort runde
macht das heißt ihr könnt ihr einfach
fragen stellen bezüglich des backens und
kochen oder auch zu meiner person und
ich werde versuchen eure fragen
aufzugreifen und dann im nächsten video
oder im übernächsten eben in diesem
werkzeug video dann zu beantworten
aber jetzt erstmal zu den oster keksen
dazu zeige ich euch einmal die zutaten
für den mürbeteig braucht ihr 200 gramm
butter die sollte zimmerer 130 gramm
puderzucker eine prise salz 1 1 300
gramm mehl eine prise backpulver und 150
gramm kokosraspeln aus diesen zutaten
wird jetzt ein web teig hergestellt und
dieser werde jetzt nicht einfach mit der
hand oder mit der maschine verknetet
sondern er wird vorher schaumig gerührt
als so puderzucker und butter das mache
ich einfach damit die kekse später
lockerer werden
und deswegen muss auch hier die butter
zimmer warm sein
ansonsten verarbeitet man eigentlich
immer kalte butter für mac falls ihr
euch diese arbeit ersparen wollte geld
einfach die zutaten zu einer glatten
mürbeteig stellt ihnen etwas kühl und
verarbeitet ihnen dann weiter die potenz
kurz verrühren und dann nach und nach
dem puderzucker einrühren
schön geschmeidig ist kommt dann noch
das salz mit dazu und das ei und jetzt
wird's noch mal etwa zwei minuten
gerührt
das kann ich dir einfach backpulver mehr
miteinander und dann kommt es gemeinsam
mit den kokosraspeln mit in eure
teigmasse
nicht das ganze mail eingearbeitet
daraus muss nämlich eingebettet werden
ich beziehe das restliche mehl noch mit
drauf und dann lasse ich das mit meinem
knicken einmal verrühren
dann gebe ich etwas mehl auf die
arbeitsfläche und gekratzt den teig aus
meiner form heraus
glatten teig
es kann auch sein dass euer teig jetzt
noch ziemlich niedrig ist aber genau
deswegen packt ihr den letzten folie ein
und gibt ihn mindestens für eine halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank
damit die butter hardware zu verarbeiten
leichter nach dem kühlen wetter stets
weiter verarbeitet ich werde heute eine
oster iphone benutzen um diese heftchen
herzustellen und später noch ein paar
blüten herstellen
falls ihr keine poster anfang habt könnt
ihr natürlich jede andere form nehmen
ich möchte euch einfach nur zeigen wie
man aus wenigen hilfsmitteln später dann
diese hasse diese phasen gesicht
herstellen kann und euch einfach diese
anregung geben falls es eben nicht hat
macht er ganz andere kekse zum beispiel
osterlämmchen oder andere osterhäschen
und fertig also weiter verarbeiten
auf dieses mal rolle ich meinen tag
wieder zwischen zwei folien aus es geht
einfach viel besser und geht nichts denn
ich benutze man nur die hälfte und habe
mir auch schon ein backpapier zum
draufpacken vorbereitet hier wird ein
kleines bisschen mehl zwischen die
folien man kurz drüber und dann lege ich
mir diese essstäbchen als abstandshalter
rein
und roller
dann stellte ich einfach eine beliebige
form aus ich mache jetzt wieder
ostereier sich die teigstücke auf mein
vorbereitetes blatt papier
manchmal stehen dann noch so ein paar
kokosraspeln ab so wie hier dann könnt
ihr einfach rein drücken und dann habt
ihr wieder einen schönen rand so sieht
das ganze dann aus ich hatte die kekse
jetzt noch etwas zehn minuten im
kühlschrank und gibt sie jetzt bei 190
grad etwa fünf bis elf minuten in den
ofen und dann müsst ihr wieder aufpassen
dass sie nicht zu brauchen werden
meine erste ladung ist aus dem ofen
gekommen wie ihr sehen könnt ist der
rand leicht braun und die mitte noch
schön hell
die waren jetzt bei 190 grad 78 minuten
im ofen zum abkühlen gebe ich die
einfach ganz vorsichtig auf einem host
getoppt und stark können sie dann
vollständig erhalten
ich habe jetzt außerdem ostereier noch
ein paar blümchen ausgestochen und
gebacken und die blümchen werde ich
jetzt mit einer zitrone puderzucker
klasse dekorieren und die häschen werde
ich dann mit blüten passte dekorieren
und jetzt zeige ich euch aber erst
einmal richtig blumen dekoriert und im
anschluss daran wie ich die osterhasen
dekoriere meine blumen die sie jetzt so
aus die sind jetzt auch schon komplett
abgekühlt die habe ich insgesamt sieben
minuten gebacken und jetzt zeige ich
euch einfach wie ich dekoriere
und so sehen dann die fertigen kekse aus
ich werde meine kekse jetzt mit blüten
passte verzieren
wer keine blüten passte möchte oder
diesem geschmack nicht mag der kann auch
einfach mit marzipan dekorieren war
sieht es auch nicht mögt dekoriert
einfach mit etwas zucker kuss oder dass
die deko komplett weg die seiner meinung
nach schränken die kekse aber am besten
wenn etwas zitrone zuckerguss trüber ist
das macht ihr einfach viel frischer und
leckerer für die augen benutze ich ganz
einfach weiße blüten passte und die habe
ich jetzt schon weit geknetet ein troll
ist jetzt auf etwas puderzucker dünn aus
und zum ausstechen benutze ich so eine
spritztour mit einem bunten loch in der
mitte und ich haben ein häschen also
stellte ich jetzt 18 augen aus
mal zur seite
ihr müsst sie auch nicht mehr abdecken
die können jetzt einfach an der luft
trocknen und diese weise bieten passte
benutze ich jetzt noch um die zähne
ausgeschlagen staat brauche ich jetzt
neue herrscher und ich mach dir etwas so
groß so etwa 15 cm breit nehme ich mir
so einen streifen und schneide hier so
heil
so dass so dass ein trapez entsteht also
unten diese karte ist länger als die
kante da oben
messer und macht damit dem messerrücken
also mit der stumpfen seite hier eine
markierung rein das quasi zwei
schneidezähne entstehen so komplett zur
seite für die schnauze nehme ich mir
etwas rosafarbene blüten passte und
wollte jetzt auch tun aus
jetzt mit einem kleinen herz ausstecher
aus
und für die nase nämlich den farben
blüten taste rolle sie aus und stech sie
dann mit mini häppchen aus falls er
zucker herzen finde dann könnt ihr auch
die nehmen dann erspart ihr euch diesen
vorkommen
ich las die blüten passt jetzt zehn
minuten antrocknen und danach steche ich
sie dann aus um die hat ihn auszustechen
nämlich ist einfach so ein ausstand ich
habe nämlich kein so kleines ausstechen
und das benutze ich eigentlich immer in
der küche wenn ich so kleine herzchen
brauchen und dann drücke ich die einfach
durch
und dazu muss eben die blüten passte
noch ein bisschen feucht sein und nicht
ganz trocken sonst bricht es nämlich
bevor ihr jetzt das gesicht dekoriert
müsst ihr erst einmal die ohren mit
kokos bestreuen und staat so spritzig
jetzt einfach etwas zuckerglasur hier in
solle vor keine zuckerglasur mag kann
zum beispiel auch weiße schokolade
nehmen
schmeckt eigentlich auch super nimmt
einfach das was er da habt
so in etwa
und dann tue ich sie einfach in kokons
streusel und dann könnte die einfach
noch ein bisschen in form bringen
ihr braucht es für jedes häschen zwei
augen ein rosa des health ein kleines
ping gesetz und einmal diese zähne und
damit die szene später schön 100 die
schnauze passen steche ich das hier
einmal noch weg also praktisch praktisch
so und dann passt sich das hier ganz gut
an
zum angeben könnt ihr entweder zucker
kleber nehmen oder einfach ein bisschen
zitronen guss zuckerguss
m
jetzt bekommen die häschen noch das
gesicht also augen und die barthaare das
mache ich mit einem lebensmittel stift
falls ihnen keinen habt das ist so an
denken eigentlich online überall kaufen
und was sie so einen nicht habt dann
könnt ihr auch einfach mit zuckerglasur
das machen dann sind eure häschen auch
schon fertig
meine kekse sind jetzt fertig und bereit
verschenkt zu werden
ihr habt gesehen ich habe mit wenig
aufwand zuckersüßer häschen gemacht also
wirklich zuckersüß und falls ihr das
rezept nach macht und nach packt dann
würde ich mich über fotos freuen und
über feedback
vergesst auch auf keinen fall die fragen
die könnt ihr unter diesem video sammeln
oder bei facebook
eine chronik schreiben ich weiß ja dass
in meinem werkzeug video aufgreifen und
beantworten
allerdings werde ich vorher
wahrscheinlich noch 12 oster videos
hochladen
damit ihr einfach noch ein paar ideen
und anregungen habt die ihr bis ostern
nachbacken könnt und dann wünsche ich
euch viel spaß dabei und bis zum
nächsten mal
denn